in the city of bakmud some days are more
difficult than others
once home to a hundred thousand people
it's now a military objective in eastern
Ukraine the Russians creep closer every
day
and this ambulance must deal with the
consequences
okay there's smoke at the end of the
lane
or possible fire
we follow the vehicle to the outskirts
of the city stop the paramedics find a
woman lying on the ground
her chest is bleeding the tips of her
shoes torn off
she calls out to her partner
this neighborhood has been pounded by
the Russians the front line just a few
kilometers away and as the crew treat
their patient another attack begins
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
phosphorus above us and felt the ground
shake from multiple explosions
we ran for the car we couldn't stay any
longer
we've left the ambulance crew there with
a woman suffered what looks like serious
injuries but that area came under attack
possibly from the air maybe grab
missiles we're not sure but we couldn't
stay it just wasn't safe
we went back to the station and waited
for the paramedics they told us Rima was
in a bad way
when the missiles hit you you hit the
ground but you didn't run away
this city has been broken sliced and
pummeled in less than a month
nowhere is safe
this car was hit by an artillery shell
the body of the driver consumed by fire
come on
but there are people trying to save
what's left of this place
members of the fire department take a
dozen calls a day like this fire in a
Timber framed house The Blaze was
threatening a city neighborhood
smoke is thick but these men don't know
what caused the fire could be a Russian
shell it could be a flare dropped from a
helicopter it's an active military area
they tugged at the roof and tried to
force their way in the firefighters
worried they'd find residents trapped
inside
to survive this war many now live
underground
anybody in there I asked
nobody there
the owners of fled said another
this is a dangerous job
it is what it is
the Ukrainian Army has retaken territory
to the North and South but the situation
in bakmud is different it's the site of
some of the most ferocious fighting in
this war
Russian intentions are written on the
walls an exhibition for everyone to see
John Sparks Sky News in eastern Ukraine